ora busto ao domingo mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer mas na
equipa do papel que dispara quando vocês
por si ono pt e como dá para ver aqui
acerta mesmo nos alf
agora a questão é será que é só fazer a
arma e vai acertar logo nos alvos
é nesta situação que vocês estão vendo
agora sim até porque é uma distância e
planta é mais ou menos 23 metros
agora vocês fizerem uma distância maior
vão ter que fazer o seguinte onde parar
várias vezes contra aquela distância que
vocês querem acertar e vão observar um
de 15 las ticos ea devon observando vão
ajustando a mira de cima para conseguir
lugar onde vou mantendo os elásticos a
cair ea partir daquele momento sempre
vocês quiserem fazer um hedge para
aquela distância é só olhar pela mira
que vai acertar aqui vocês podem ver
mais parte de si na parte final do vídeo
em que o fisco é 4 e essa este método
distância até mais ou menos pois vocês
viram aqui você tava mas é porque fiz um
ajuste enquanto jack fazer para tocar a
atenção a partida de abertura tem ficar
virada pra vocês e vão dobrar desta
maneira para fazer a parte da guerra é
como é que não fique muito grande eu caí
porque se você fizer está para guerra
muito grande para o tucano vai ficar
mais pequena então mas na época contando
que no romance the night e eu fiz esta
obra aqui não é obrigatório mas já
consegue pôr fica mais resistente e faça
aquela cultura é porque porque depois é
preciso dar um força ea parte do cano
então fazendo aquela abertura do pois
vão conseguir introduzir lá é uns
pulinhos a cair foi do papel que vocês
já vão ver mais para frente
nesta quarta e só por cola para cola não
decola para ficar tudo isolado
e põe também nesta parte estou por aqui
agora que não precisava mas é só por uma
questão estrutural e vai ficar mais
resistente ea parte da frente é só para
encaixarmos elástico e agora fazer o
parto ótica pronta gente espera que
nesta parte do pessoal varia bastante
fiz aqui uma maneira muito simplista ok
mas se vocês fizerem variações podem
mandar três dias para a página do
facebook
a nova página do facebook porque alguém
roubou a última até aí eu espero que
aproveite bastante e ainda não tira essa
do ar porque andei lá algum tempo leite
ainda não passei para a nova campanha
toque é só uma questão de tempo
treinando bastante preocupado agora é só
quando já estou fazer aquela deitando
leite que pronta aquilo dava erro é não
sei que eu fui lá e já não há pressa
então estou fazer aqui o profeta o
shopping brevemente vai ter lá é e oeste
empataram por um caminho mas tem andado
mesmo muito ocupada que só vejo aqui que
eu estou fazendo bastante simples é só
fazer o cano principal hub central
bush e blair papel na extremidade para
ficar sem mais volumoso
aí eu não precisava fazer dois que no
dia em que começa aqui no final prenda
com fita mas não sei falar tudo no
juntei uma outra edir em que ela parte
mais frágil é porque se não tirarem não
vai funcionar e vai ao chocar arma toda
a corrupção do elástico que neste caso
não vai mudar muito porque são elástico
como esconder é o caso do shopping que é
vendedora é cantada forçaram muito
grandes não pudessem conhecer esta parte
mas ficava tudo e agora o santos fazer
duas tiras de papel bastante parecido
com o que vocês viram inicialmente quase
nada é igual só que o produto se sabe
colar no final estou a fazer outra vez
para que algumas pessoas não fiquem
confusos região muito importante que
vocês deixarem sempre aquela pequena
distância
lá no centro na primeira dobra na semana
o dólar nem mesmo para a linha do centro
uma tira vai ser para vocês aprenderem a
partir da ótica a arma e outro tira é
pra fazer o que tinha eo que vai ficar
móvel e vejam que como é que o prefeito
é só deslizar e encaixa na perfeição não
vai ficar nada advogado
está atrás do xingu os tiras da ótica e
vou começar aqui por dobraram mãe amou
game naquela parte de cima para ser mais
fácil contornar parte lindo e que é
nessa ótica e aí é só aprender com fita
faz muita diferença se você usar uma
fita maior a mais pequena porque no
final vocês vão ajustar ótica para
acertarmos para os comerciantes aumentem
a gente que nunca viu tamanha não é só
dobrar para dentro pra ficar tudo em
volta e é bom que você dobra em porque
assim vai ficar mais resistente aquela
parte não corta entendeu do praia e
agora é só aprender com fita tudo quando
é ser menos uma parte do que vocês vão
ver na qual é que não devem impor fita
para permitir o movimento dub e tentar
explicar não vou conseguir explicar pra
você e então você já conversar aqui mais
para frente
você vai parar na internet por fita e
agora fazer obtido novamente é um erro
encaixe na arma vejam quanto é que tem
que deixar e dobre é 90 graus
portanto vocês brincarem muito bem nesta
quarta e façam do outro lado também
provariam que nem tem poder confiar e
claro que você tem que usar esses
detalhes podem ficar mais bonitos mal dá
para perceber que há pessoas que gostam
fazer um book de frente usando aquelas
fitas coloridas tamanho e que faça a
escola estava inclinado porque isso
ajuda bastante a ser o elástico e vejam
o sítio onde diz que não tenho por fita
e o retiro vai ficar mais fixo aqui não
vai abalar muito então é muito melhor e
vejam que a inclinação do corpo que
estou fazer secreto não vai funcionar
muito painéis e pronto solos na época já
está feita é agora só falta mesmo
carregar e disparar
por isso eu estou usará que os latics
que estão muito na moda para fazer
pulseiras acho que ainda estão se vocês
não tiverem não há problema podem usar
os normais só que tem que diminuir o
tamanho do modo que quando em caixas na
arma fica explicado ao máximo aqui e
estou chegando ao fim e os perto de um
estado se vocês quiserem ajudar o canal
de voz life e se inscrevam para
acompanhar os próximos vídeos estiver em
alguma sugestão do projeto é só deixar
nos comentários que eu vou fazendo claro
que não faço toda a gente porque são
muitas sugestões à maggi tem feito
muitas coisas que vocês têm proibido é
este o dobro do investido é o próximo
vídeo tchau